what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
mediocre tutorials and reviews
how issa rae don't know who that is
escaped the
wall to marry a high value man before i
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
okay i don't know who this is but she's
pretty so let's see
okay when i think about issa rae her
personality is a lot different than
the majority of women that we go over
from a bad behavior perspective
all over the youtube channel so i think
it's important to talk about these
situations especially when they reach
their goal okay there's a very important
other reason why i wanted to talk about
this as well but let's look at
what the article says real quick okay
she and now she is married
on monday by posting stunning photos of
her
in france all right go down here you can
see some of the photos i'll leave a link
to this
uh down below uh actually knowing that
she's 36 years old and looking at
the gentleman to the right he looks 36
if not younger okay maybe just looks
young for his age the same way i do but
anyway
so you can see right here on the
instagram pros impromptu photo shoot in
a custom vera wang
dress da da my girls came to help me but
they coincidentally had on the same
dress
so she's being tongue-in-cheek okay then
i took a few flicks with somebody's
husband
so this was her announcement okay very
tongue-in-cheek with this announcing
of um this very important pivotal step
within
her life okay now coming out a little
bit further in the article it says ray36
has been notably private about her
relationship with the businessman
okay but some speculated back in 2019
that she was engaged when she appeared
on the cover of essence with what looked
like an
engagement ring okay here's the reason
why i wanted to cover this outside of
the other things that i mentioned one of
the biggest things that i think a lot of
dudes are
scared about when they talk about the
concept of
marrying the modern lady today there's
actually a ton of goddamn reasons
because i would say more dudes are
scared of the divorce than the actual
marriage
in it of itself so you know what i'm
saying especially being the bread and
winner and
you know my assumption is is that she's
the breadwinner but i could be wrong
even there's really not a lot to go off
of this particular article
however i think it says a lot in the
social media era
today as to have someone that doesn't
post publicly
about relationships i actually think
that
social media leads to way more
dysfunction within relationships and
breakups in relationships because of
the sharing nature of it i think that
you know yeah
i've learned lessons with this yeah
it does a relationship is something that
should like for example the first time
my boyfriend like i posted a video with
my boyfriend we weren't even dating it
was just like a video we did together
the entire internet proceeded to tell me
how much uglier i was than the last girl
he talked to
like stuff like that happens with social
media between the two people not the two
people
and then for everyone else for public
consumption and entertainment
not to mention the delusion or the lack
of reality that is created
for the modern woman today if they take
a look at
how marriage is purported through the
highlights of
other people's lives and what that
comparison can do
within themselves because i think that
way more women would get the outcome of
marriage
more often they focused on being good
partners or healing
the trauma or the ptsd that existed
within themselves versus
emulating the highlights that they see
with on
the media i think a lot of younger
people today
get it misconstrued what social media
actually
is okay essentially it's a company that
is
crowdsourcing entertainment for
everybody else
so they don't make any money unless
there's a network of people
that are creating content to entertain
other people that's really what it is
that's why i'm not on social media
except for from a business perspective
it's about to say you're literally on
social media right because it really
doesn't have
a lot of benefit within my life
now what we talk about on this channel
all day is the concept of
those who want to get married for the
wedding
as opposed to wanting to get married for
the marriage okay and i think it's a key
indicator along with
her extremely valuable temperament
in representing a woman today
also with this idea within especially
being in media
not having to put [ __ ] on jump street
and it made me actually think of a
article
that talked about being able to achieve
your
goals and how being public with your
goals actually de-incentivizes you
to complete your goals let's go over
that article title
why sharing your goals makes them less
achievable damn the more committed to
your goals the more secretive you should
be
about them okay let's read on social
media is saturated with new year's
resolutions many having to do with
losing weight
of course see it's interesting because i
think i've lost more weight like i'm
down
five pounds in two weeks which is like
pretty good that's like could be 10 in a
month
well i but we'll see but um i actually
feel like
i achieved them more because i'm like oh
i posted about this
i gotta do it you know according to
nielsen.com the top two
2015 new year's resolutions were to stay
fit and healthy this article was
actually
written back in 2018 but that doesn't
matter
okay it is not surprising that gym
memberships tend to trend
upwards during the first few months of
the year how many of us
have announced our goals to lose weight
to the world and end up staying
the same or even gaining more weight the
next year
you can think of resolutions as setting
goals or setting intentions being
satisfied with progress
towards our goal is associative with
positive emotions
these positive emotions provide the
motivation necessary to continue
pursuing
our goals unfortunately setting a goal
does not always culminate in a desirable
change thus a critical solution would
have to address how to close the gap
between intention and implementation
pay attention one demonstrable way to
close this gap
is to privatize our intentions
right people tend to make their goals
public but research has shown us that
publicizing intentions
might jeopardize chances to achieve
our goals guys immediately when i think
about this i actually think about this
youtube channel right here when i
set it for myself like yo i want to be
a youtube creator right i got so
hungry i dived down deep i didn't tell
nobody what was going on
i just created because i knew at the end
of the day if i publicized my
goals i wouldn't be able to necessarily
rely on
the friends within my life to continue
it if the product is good
people will follow the product peter
published a paper titled the social
reality widen
the intention behavior so is he saying
she beat the wall because she didn't
talk about her relationship publicly
your gap in this paper and
colleagues demonstrate the deleterious
effects
of making intentions public in field in
lab
settings the conclusions was that when
we publicize our goals especially the
ones that have to do with our identity
our goal-related performance is
compromised ironically this effect was
only found for participants
who are very committed to their goal all
right
lessons learned is that the more
passionate you are about the goals the
more secretive you should be
about them now here's the actual
explanation of the summary of the study
why would making our goals public reduce
the likelihood of achieving them well
making goals in any progress towards
implementation generate
positive reward feelings okay where does
the positive reward comes from it comes
from the dopamine
in our brains in order for these
emotions to be motivational
until our goals are realized the reward
has to be time
released our brain cannot afford to be
logically mathematical
reality machines at all times that would
be too costly when our brain is tricked
into thinking that the goal was achieved
it stops investing energy towards
further implementation
actions what is it that this means all
right
what this means is that when you talk
about your goals when you publicize your
goals
when you go up on social media and say
this is what i'm doing this is what i'm
starting
you know whether or not it's that weight
loss goal or for the
five ladies that have done i've been
here i want to get married that or even
a couple of the dudes in here that want
to have the goal of getting married
publicizing it you get an immediate
dopamine reward
of publicizing of getting people
attached to the idea that this is
something that you will try
to do so you receive that reward
it lessens the likelihood that you will
complete that reward
because you've received the influx of
the dopamine to your brain
the validation the affirmation of what
you can see in those comments so forth
the like button that was hit
so then you feel it there but when you
think about this you have to think about
the concept of delayed gratification
think how much more impactful it would
be if
you don't tell people about your goals
right
and then you complete your goals and
then it's an announcement that i had
this as a goal
but not only just that but i have
completed it
and because you delay that gratification
because you want that goal so much you
go at it that much
harder in order to achieve it and the
psychological reason is that you haven't
felt that influx of dopamine into your
brain that reward deep into your brain
so you continue to pursue it out until
you get it as you can see right here
the more others admire our goals the
more dopamine rush we get and the less
likely
we are to execute them into the future
doing the necessary actions to implement
them
guys i'm gonna leave this article down
below as you can see there's a lot more
information that's in it that's gonna
describe it even more that's really why
i wanted to talk about this particular
article so you guys can continue to
cement the ideas
of delayed gratification and announcing
the things that you're trying to do
i don't know if i'd buy that but she
beat the wall because she didn't tell
people about it
i mean just logically she beat the wall
because she's stunning she looks young
and she's fit i don't know what her
personality's like but i'm sure that
plays into
it um i mean maybe that helped i don't
know i just think the other factors were
probably more influential but let me
know what you think in the comments
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification bell i'll
talk to you guys
next time